for example Socrates says I'm not a good
speaker I'm just GNA have to like you
know talk the way ordinarily do um is
Socrates a good
speaker yeah he's he's a great speaker
particularly when he can bring somebody
else into the dialogue and then recite
their words or perhaps make them up on
the spot we don't know whether theod
existed or not and give up an entire
speech he's able to replicate this this
sort of stuff he does know what he's
doing he kind of pretends like he
doesn't irony is a pretending to be less
capable or knowledgeable than you
actually are so as to get people off
their guard and this is actually you
know a good thing to do in a lot of
contexts I I highly recommend it to you
because people will say all sorts of
things when they think that you're
actually not that bright they'll reveal
things to you that they wouldn't
ordinarily reveal